KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are at Founder
World in San Francisco.
I'm joined in the
studio today by Iddo.
He is the founder
and CEO of Invi.
IDDO TAI: Yes.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank
you for joining.
IDDO TAI: Thank
you for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
And tell me a little
bit about what is Invi.
IDDO TAI: So Invi is
a rich media messaging
app that replaces on your
Android device your regular SMS
app and just makes it better.
KORY JEFFREY: How so?
What makes it better?
IDDO TAI: So once
you install Invi,
it takes all over
your SMS experience.
And it just works slick.
And it looks cool.
And it has a lot of rich media
integration on top of that.
So you have mini apps.
You can watch YouTube while
messaging with your friends.
You can play
games-- [INAUDIBLE],
all that, and immediately
share with your friends.
And when you get
rich media, it's
not just a blue link that takes
you away from your experience.
If I send you a
YouTube, if you click,
you cannot chat with me anymore.
So what we do, we
changed it to a widget.
And you continue watching
it while messaging
with your friends.
KORY JEFFREY: And this is all
from within the app itself?
IDDO TAI: Exactly.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's pretty slick.
So there's been a lot of
interesting, big things
happening in the chat
space, obviously,
with Facebook buying WhatsApp,
and then WeChat investing
in Kik in a big way.
What are your thoughts
on the space in general?
IDDO TAI: I think that all
those messaging apps are great.
And over 20% of Americans
has WhatsApp or Kik
and they use it as their
international messaging abroad,
but they don't use it
between themselves.
KORY JEFFREY: Interesting.
IDDO TAI: They still send SMS.
And I think that my take on it,
it's because SMS is free here.
And also, we don't have a
good internet connection
on our mobile phones.
If you say, hey, I'm downstairs
and you're sending a WhatsApp,
it will not get there on time.
So with your cousin
abroad, it's OK.
With your buddy that you're
waiting for, it's not OK.
And therefore, SMS is strong.
We just take it over and we
make an iMessage experience.
So if both of us are
on good connections,
it will be over the internet.
But if not, it will send an SMS.
So it ensures that your
friend's going to get a message.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
How long have you
been working on this?
IDDO TAI: Over three years.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
IDDO TAI: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: Any big milestones
over those three years?
IDDO TAI: Yes.
I think that understanding
the market needs
and why other messaging apps
are not successful for the US
market for most
of your messaging,
and just bring
them what they want
and tailor it to the Android.
That's what we're
all excited about.
And our user really likes it.
KORY JEFFREY: That's awesome.
So we're at Founder World.
There's been thousands of
people walking around today.
What attracted
you to this event?
IDDO TAI: I think that
our mission in general
is to just upgrade your
communication, make it reach.
And this was a good
opportunity to talk about Invi
and to see how
other entrepreneurs,
a lot of other entrepreneurs
trying to raise money.
They ask us questions, how
did you guys raise money?
What did you guys go through?
We just share our story.
That's what I love doing.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
So you just came off the stage.
And is that where you
were sharing your story?
What was the main
message you were
giving while you were speaking?
IDDO TAI: I think the main
message was on the stage.
They asked a few tough
questions there, like,
how do you deal with
investors, what is your rank.
It was all around, the crowd was
very interested about funding
your app, your startup.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
Probably very topical
for a lot of people here.
IDDO TAI: Yes.
I have very extreme
opinions about that.
KORY JEFFREY: Any in particular
that you want to share?
IDDO TAI: I think
the one thing that I
shared there, as
an entrepreneur,
you're in the mindset of
sometimes you go to investors,
say look, you don't
have enough users,
or this is a space we don't
understand so much about.
And practically, they're
saying you no in a nice way.
I think you should thank
them for their time
and you should leave the room.
You should go outside the
building to the sidewalk.
You go in the middle of the
street and just shout, next!
KORY JEFFREY: And just move on.
IDDO TAI: Then move
on and find people
that are inspiring you
and you want to work with,
that are extraordinary,
that can really help.
And we have an amazing
group of investors
that helps us, that really
become friends and understand
the hard task we go through,
but also understand the outcome.
Once we solve it, rich media
messaging for the US market
can be huge.
And people who just made it
in China on WeChat, $5 billion
of revenue, 850
million active users.
The CTO of the group just led
the round of investing in us
and joined the board, together
with the CTO of Weibo,
which is the Twitter of China.
So there's a lot of people
that done that that really
understand.
I think you should
really want to find
the top, top extraordinary
people in your space
and try to work with
them and learn from them.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
I didn't know Weibo
had invested locally.
That's really cool.
IDDO TAI: It's the CTO himself.
He has another company.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's even better.
IDDO TAI: Yes.
Working with the right people.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
So as you walk around
today, you see a whole bunch
of different
technologies, from VR
to robots to all sorts
of different things.
Is there anything, other
than the chat space,
that kind of gets you really
excited about the future
of tech?
IDDO TAI: So many.
I'm personally into making
communication between people
better.
I think it's a key.
But any technology that
just makes life better
gets me excited.
Make our life better and
make my wife less mad at me.
Makes everything better.
KORY JEFFREY: Improves the
communication between you,
right?
IDDO TAI: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: So last question.
What is your favorite
Google technology?
IDDO TAI: Google has a lot
of strong technologies,
and we are dependent
on a lot of them.
Google Cloud Messaging,
and the Android platform.
But if you ask me
as a consumer what
I use the most, what I like
the most, it's pretty vanilla,
but it's Google Maps.
It's saved my marriage.
I just turn it on.
It's working.
And then I can be free
to drive and communicate.
KORY JEFFREY: That's awesome.
IDDO TAI: No more one person
navigate, the other one
driving.
I can do them both.
KORY JEFFREY: And then you
both have something else
to blame if you get lost.
IDDO TAI: Exactly.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank you
very much for joining us.
IDDO TAI: Thank
you for having me.
I appreciate it.
It was fun.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank
you for joining us.
We are on location at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]